i think grapefruit should be in
everybody's house in the bottom of the
refrigerator if you ain't got no
grapefruits in the bottom of your
refrigerator
you tripping come see me i'll stock you
up
yo what's good i'm young dog these are
my essentials
these are a few jury pieces probably
like
30 percent of my jury this one
it's my son's favorite we got the sonic
blue diamonds rvs that's a lamborghini
truck right there
of course you got my label paper route
piece
it's a 19 carat it's right here cost me
seven hundred thousand
a lot of earrings different sizes i got
about four watches in here
plus this one i got on five just my
son's watching
i don't know why it's in my box one on
one richard you won't see nobody with
this right here
i designed it i did it you'll never see
nobody put blue diamonds in a richard
mill
i really just like being different my
cousin
my brother key glock he bought me this
watch i got on
it's like my favorite watch i got a lot
of blue pieces
because i just like being different and
i don't want to look like everybody
else you see if you look in today's
really
the fashion of jury a lot of people mock
this style
of their of their logo and hip-hop and i
started that
but i ain't gonna say nothing about that
y'all have fun with it
yeah i got different kind of water this
alkaline water
everybody else they having fiji water
aquafina
and i ain't having none of that i'm
having real deal
alkaline water 10.5 ph
i always have money on me it's just like
you always need it you never know
what's going to happen what's going to
occur like the cash really be for
like when i'm dealing with people like
strip clubs like if i go to strip club
i'm going to have cash like hey bring me
20 000 ones
if you go to 20. you know what i'm
saying it might be old money that's from
a show
or something if it's just a typical day
of regular day
i probably have from like a
60 to a hundred thousand on me it really
just depends and it depends on which
bag i grab house shoes
i love house shoes i really really
really love house shoes like
they collectible items to me i'm always
in the studio
i'm always standing up i'm always giving
orders
i'm always taking orders and it's like i
just like being comfortable
i bought a couple just a few prayer
house shoes
i probably own like 30 per house shoes
25 per house
and i leave a lot of house shoes i lose
a lot of house shoes also
hotels different houses like
yeah my favorite pro with me right now
they
they just dolce cabana house shoes
and they made out of a bear they look
like bear why you wearing them it looks
like birds on your feet
i love them my next item is something
that means a lot to me like
it's a card from my aunt she like my
mama too at the same time
she been fighting cancer and she's super
strong
and it's just she said it's real
meaningful where isn't her so
like when i get down or when i feel like
i'm against the world i ain't nobody
understanding me
don't nobody get me nobody in my corner
i had to remind myself like i got real
love
so i keep this with me and i read it
like
i don't take it everywhere i go but i
gotta read it and keep it like
keep it close she gave me this for
valentine's day
it's a valentine's day card she told me
i was a valentine
shot my auntie until you read them my
next essential
cocoa butter i can't go nowhere without
this
i'm dark skinned so i don't like lotion
lotion don't do nothing for me it's too
thin cocoa butter is thick
and it feels good on my skin and it
makes me look good
i always use cocoa butter but i think
this brand palmer's i've been using it
for years
a long time i love palmer's you know
these the little ones like at home
i had the big jars and all the probably
like two of the bathrooms
and all of my book bags i always have a
little jar
i love the smell i like the texture of
it i like everything about it it's just
cocoa butter does body good
my next item is my grapefruits i love
grapefruit
i probably eat a grapefruit or two
grapefruits a day cause i always love
grapefruit since y'all
kid they juicy i love them cold
they got to be cold in the refrigerator
i can eat them whenever for breakfast
lunch
dinner dessert like i eat one when i get
up and i eat one in the middle of the
day like
on the way to the studio or in the
studio i'm doing stuff because i'm
always busy
most of the time i forget to eat i can't
go nowhere
without these these my floss picks i'm
not talking about just floss picks
they got to be scoped floss pigs the
green ones if it's not green and if it's
not a scope floss pick i'm not putting
it in my mouth
they feel good they're comfortable all
them other floss pigs
they be too little and too thin and they
hurt your mouth when you're doing it
and just for the record too cause a lot
of y'all don't know how to floss right
when you use these floss pigs
you throw it away you use a floss pick
every tooth you don't supposed to take
one floss pick and do your whole mouth
you're doing it wrong i don't like the
regular floss the string
you do this like i don't like that
i think i look better and look more cool
with these
you see what i'm saying my next
essentials
are my telephones these
are the utensils that i work my magic on
i'm
always busy and i'm always doing stuff
i'm always talking on the phone i'm
always sending emails
i'm always texting i'm the guy with the
jack of all trades
i'm the ceo i'm an artist i'm a producer
director or more everything so i'm
always on my phone they go dead a lot so
when they go dead
i pick up the other one i got another
two iphones
back up iphones in the truck my kids
call
all of my phones ring no i mean one time
you know i mean so you learn how to work
this item right here
the right way and not just scrolling on
social media and looking and looking
like and really know how to use this
device
you can make yourself a millionaire like
easily all you need is just
a little phone and use your brain take
it to the bank
chinching my next item that i have
all day every day is water this is my
favorite water
i don't like too many waters this water
tastes good
it tastes pure see how clear it is how
good it is
how the bottle look you know i mean like
you got a
9.5 ph i try to drink
a lot but i don't drink much as i need
to so i'm not gonna sit here and lie and
say i drink a gallon
i probably drink like three of these a
day though scrumptious
every entertainer is like a a bad
collector
this is one of my favorite ones right
now it's the chrome heart book bag
you won't see too many people with this
bag it's comfortable and it's fun and
it's not too big and it's not too small
it's just enough to walk around with
some racks on you
a bottle of water on you your grapefruit
on you
and your floss pigs phones in my pocket
everything else in the bag
this is like an everyday bag grab on the
way out the house
go take the kid to school go to the
studio
shoot a video go to pull up on gq
yeah i mean yo gq
i appreciate y'all for coming through
checking out my essentials
love y'all peace